et aujourd'hui mardi 8 mars nous fêtons
la journée internationale des droits des
femmes une journée consacrée au combat
pour l'égalité hommes femmes la parité
mais aussi la lutte contre les
stéréotypes et les clichés à cette
occasion et jusqu'au 11 mars
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines propose la semaine de lutte
étudiante pour le droit des femmes
aujourd'hui le hâle vauban de
l'université accueillir des stands tenus
par les étudiants pour sensibiliser le
public à cette problématique
quiz discussion est mûr l'expression
étaient ainsi proposés écoutez ces
précisions recueillies au micro de
mélanie poké
sensibiliser les étudiants et les
étudiantes aux droits des femmes parce
que il ya encore beaucoup des kings j'ai
entendu dire ah oui les égalités enfin
en france havas non ça va pas il ya
encore beaucoup d'inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes est
et il ya des gens qui ne savent pas et
qui de leva ue qui le subissent mais qui
savent pas que c'est du sexisme et en
cette journée de lutte pour la parité et
l'égalité hommes-femmes nous vous avons
laissé la parole à vous messieurs sur le
sujet nous vous avons demandé si vous
aviez un message à faire passer en cette
journée internationale du droit des
femmes écoutés et regardés
souhaite qu'elle trouve l'amour celles
non pas autrement quelle légalité
qu'elle mérite à situation égale et à
travail égal voilà je pense qu'elles
sont le coeur de l'être la soufrière ces
individus avant tout au même titre qu'un
homme donc il ya des différences faut en
parler ne faut pas créer quelque chose
de négatif en intro de fixette
autour de cette question un message
d'espoir avec tout ce qu'on entend les
libertés qui sont bafoués les femmes qui
souffrent à travers le monde donc plus
d'égalité avec les hommes défendent et
au droit aujourd'hui c'est le moment de
les exprimer les femmes elles sont
toutes belles déjà et puis
il faut faire les élections d exception
aujourd'hui et pour précisions c'est
bien aujourd'hui la journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
non pas seulement la fête des femmes il
est important de souligner les siens